[Music]
all right we're going to
ashley in oklahoma city hey ashley how
are you
hi i'm good how are you good what's
going on
well earlier this year my husband and i
found out that my mother-in-law
had taken credit cards and loans out in
his name
that he had no idea and what
we know that we got our first mortgage
and we had a crazy interest rate and
they had called me
and a credit card had been turned over
to collections
we've talked to her about it and you
know asked her to buckle down and pay it
and she's not
i mean she's giving us the minimum
payment but that's all we're getting
and anytime we try to talk to her about
it it's oh for pitiful me
and i don't know what to do okay okay
let's back up here so first of all first
of all
playing the victim is a strategy
it's called manipulation so i don't care
if she's
your mom my mom anybody's mom doesn't
matter that she's a sweet little
mother-in-law or mother that's
manipulative incredibly it's also
theft that was theft identity theft
so again even if you're related it
doesn't change the fact that it's
illegal
and not okay at all in any way
so um ashley i don't know
if you do this or your husband does this
i would say he would need to do it but
you can tell me whether or not this is
realistic
but there needs to be a conversation a
very different conversation that looks
like this
you pay it off or i'm turning you in
for identity theft yeah has that
happened
that is the conversation i've tried to
push him to that
but he seems to be taking it a little
easy on her
yeah how much money are we talking about
um the personal loan was ten thousand
and then
about another four or five in credit
cards
and her excuse was i did it to help you
guys
okay well i gotta know more what do you
mean she did it to help
what was it for what was the money spent
on that's supposed to help you
nothing literally nothing okay we are
very self-esteem
we take care of ourselves okay your
husband
your husband needs to grow a pair
it's time where's the hustle where's the
dad in this situation
just say it ken just and he's on the
road so he really he didn't realize this
was going on
but okay so so this is a family listen
i hate that you're even calling um i
hope you maybe
maybe show your husband this call i'd
like to speak to him for a moment what's
his name
his name's bo bo where are you bo okay
so i'm going to talk to bo for a second
and you can get today's youtube show and
you can
get it right to this point bo here's the
deal man your wife's got more
guts than you do and your mom
is is in is in a very unhealthy place
and you're allowing it to happen and it
is affecting your life and your marriage
and this needs to be dealt with i think
christie's right i go with her and say
mom dad
fix it now pay it off now or i'm turning
you in
but you're but you don't have the guts
to do that bo and so here's what's going
to happen
because you're afraid to be a man and
talk to mommy
and tell her that what she did was wrong
you're going to end up having such sick
toxicity and resentment toward hurt
because this is never
going to go away and your dad has
has the same problem you have neither
one of you
you or your dad have got
what it takes you just don't because you
have done something by now and you need
to grow a pair both of you maybe you
share the pair
and you talk and sit down and get this
handle because this is bad
they need to fix it and i think the time
for talking is over
ashley i'm sorry i i i'm sorry you had
to call in
the conversation needs to go like this
pay it off by this date
or we're turning you in and then when
that date comes
turn her in and follow through this is
illegal
and insanely manipulative and the more
you allow it to happen
the more it is on you don't let it
happen
fix it now